[Music]
I'm welcome to Hannity and tonight we
begin with breaking news sources have
now confirmed that Joe Biden's personal
office at the UPenn Biden Center was in
fact searched by the FBI way back in
November now the topic of the search top
secret classified documents and oddly
enough the most transparent
Administration in history according to
the White House they never mentioned the
incident Christopher Ray mayor Garland
they never bragged that they approved it
either not Joe Biden not Kareem
Jean-Pierre not Ron Clane nobody told us
they also failed to mention that top
secret documents were in fact discovered
at the UPenn Biden Center on November
2nd November 8th was the midterm
election nearly a week before the
midterms now they hid this discovery
from you the American people until it
was leaked to the Press but that was a
whopping 68 days later and by the way in
the interim while all this was going on
they did in fact appoint a special
counsel to invest Donald Trump so as of
now we still have no idea why the
classified documents were uncovered in
the first place and so proclaimed most
transparent White House in history well
they won't tell us a thing so what are
they hiding and do we have a dual
justice system once again one system for
the clintons and bidens and one system
for the the trumps and everyone else now
so far batches of classified documents
they have been discovered in five
separate different locations and in
addition to the UPenn Biden Center while
other materials were found at Biden's
office in Delaware even his garage piled
up next to that beautiful Corvette and
some of the documents were from his time
as vice president while other material
dated back to his days as a U.S senator
and yet so far as we know Biden's beach
house that's never been the subject of
an FBI search maybe it was but clearly
they're not going to tell us and weren't
these places you know why weren't they
rated like Mar-A-Lago interesting Minds
interesting question now by the way the
University of Delaware also has not been
subject to a raid either now since 2011
the university has been home to a
massive amount of Biden documents
according to Jonathan Turley quote the
president effectively locked away his
records by giving them to the university
which has claimed for a decade that it
is still working to organize and catalog
the documents over a decade now neither
Biden or the university will allow
anybody any access to that material in
other words a public university that
many of you pay for with your tax
dollars has been actively protecting a
political candidate now president for
more than a decade and now this well
rather low ranked uh third tier party
school of Joe Biden might be home to a
trove of top secret classified material
we don't know now we're talking about 33
pallets of documents delivered on two
trucks it's a lot of Doc documents that
would include over 1800 cartons of paper
and 415 gigabytes of electronic records
but just a few months after forcibly
rating Mar-A-Lago the FBI the doj the
National Archives they no longer seem
and interested in any way shape manner
reform in securing all of these
classified documents why is that hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else